what's wonderful about the road trip is
that it's about desire
first off the landscape as its framed
through the window as an astonishing
thing it is never enough you always must
have more you must see more you have to
continue you end when you're exhausted
we think that we can reinvent ourselves
on the road we think we can find
something whether it's more money a
sense of ourselves you know some kind of
release from the banality of everyday
life this goes back to the pioneer
spirit whatever that meant into this
notion we were always going to move west
I'm not sure how valid that idea is
anymore you know I think road trips are
increasingly destination driven they're
not so much about the process anymore
you